[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
il
depuis le 1er mars la mjc boby-lapointe
organise un rassemblement de jeunes
musiciens qui s'appelle et nos france
ce rassemblement a pour objectif
l'échangé le partage des musiques
traditionnelles des participants donc ce
sont 25 jeunes qui viennent d'un peu
partout dans le monde qui viennent je
crois aller plus loin de l'inde et du
chili
sur le continent américain
pendant cinq jours ils ont travaillé
échanges et préparer un concert est là
aujourd'hui et demain ils vont aller à
la rencontre des habitants du territoire
ou dans les écoles comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
ils vont aussi voir des résidences de
personnes âgées les pattes de villebon
au collège enfin voilà ils vont un peu
partout dans les centres sociaux de
palaiseau et
maisons de quartier et donc ils vont par
petits groupes échanger avec le public
après ces jours de préparation des
changes de partage et de rencontre par
petits groupes des habitants du
territoire paris saclay les jeunes
musiciens feront trois concerts donc 3
conserve tout public et deux concerts
scolaires pour finir ce rassemblement de
jeunes musiciens
nous ça fait dix ans qu'on organise ce
rassemblement de jeunes musiciens
la mjc villebon travaille énormément sur
la musique et ça il ya un plus quand on
fait ce genre de rassemblement c'est
parce que c'est il ya des d'autres
cultures qui viennent chez nous qu'ils
partagent donc ça met en mouvement un
peu sur sur d'autres esthétiques que
celle que nous faisons au tour de plus
tôt des musiques actuelles et du jazz
donc de travailler là avec sur ces
esthétiques à de musique traditionnelle
au niveau du monde c'est très
enrichissant pour pour les musiciens de
la mjc mais aussi du territoire puisque
on va aussi sur le territoire
[Applaudissements]